[Music]
now
more than ever it's important to stay as
healthy as
possible having a balanced diet can help
the world health organization suggests
eating a variety
of food from different nutritional
groups
including plenty of fruit and vegetables
the who also recommends eating a diet
rich in whole grains and
nuts limiting your intake of sugar
salt and fat
[Music]
practicing good food hygiene to avoid
becoming sick of foodborne disease
[Music]
and limiting your consumption of alcohol
research shows improving nutrition helps
support
optimal immune function
so if you catch covid19 your immune
system
may be better equipped to fight it
[Music]
this is dw's covert 19 special i'm kate
ferguson thanks for joining me
the past few months have been tough
living in constant fear of getting sick
or losing your job
can make you feel like you're not in
control one thing you do have some
agency over though is your diet and
as our next report shows good nutrition
can have a major
impact on health outcomes
few really like hospital food but it's
more than just a question of taste
nutrition is vital and most clinics and
hospitals pay too little attention to a
well-balanced diet
dr viola andreessen from hamburg has
been dealing with the effects of poor
hospital nutrition on patients for 20
years
these people simply are more at risk of
being in the icu for longer
of having to stay in hospital longer of
increased complications and are even
more at risk of dying from their disease
geriatric physician dr martin vilcom has
many weak patients
and he sees the dangers of poor
nutrition every day
eating an unbalanced diet especially in
the elderly causes them to lose weight
quickly and lose substance
the body can no longer heal wounds as
quickly
people get dizzy they fall over problems
flare up in days and weeks when the food
and liquids are not balanced and above
all not sufficient enzymes
the doctor's experience is borne out by
a major swiss study
two thousand participants with already
poor nutrition took part in the study
one thousand were given regular hospital
food the other half were given a
healthier alternative
within the group that received the
superior diet outcomes were
significantly better
with 15 percent fewer complications and
27 percent fewer deaths
a few days of hospital food won't harm
most people but the very ill have often
already lost weight and strength
beforehand
here at the israelite hospital in
hamburg a specialist nutrition team
takes care of these high-risk patients
selecting them for special attention as
soon as they're admitted
in a three-day period 21 of 53 newly
admitted patients
were noticed by the experts
there are various methods for measuring
malnutrition
this device measures how much strength
there is in the hands
or how much muscle and fat tissue is on
the back of the hand
or even how is body tissue composed a
special scale shows the proportion of
muscle and fat
and of course blood values is there a
lack of
iron sodium potassium or protein
patients who are malnourished are given
extra care
special nutrition filled shakes with
cucumber or beetroot
and extra protein are sweetened with
banana and chocolate to improve strength
and charge the batteries for recovery
helps to heal wounds for example zinc
serves to ward off infection
[Applause]
the key to making a full recovery is
freshly prepared food
rich in nutrients if clinics pay proper
attention to nutrition
a lot can be achieved through normal
diet
sometimes it only takes a little extra
effort with nutrition
to achieve great results
let's talk now to professor annika
wagner from the institute of nutritional
sciences at the university of geesen
professor wagner the study we saw in the
report just now really reiterated what
an incredibly crucial role nutrition
plays in our general health and as well
our ability to heal
do you think this issue is getting
enough attention during the pandemic
i think the effect of nutrition on our
health in the context of the current
pandemic is underestimated
a high number of people suffer from
different diet dependent diseases such
as obesity diabetes type 2 and
hypertension
and we know that these patients have a
significantly higher risk for severe
courses of covid19
that means that through a sustainable
change of unhealthy dietary habits
towards a healthy well-balanced diet
will improve these diet dependent
diseases and simultaneously
would decrease the risk for a severe
cause of a corvette 19 infection
however as a change in our nutritional
behavior is a long-term goal
long-term concepts need to be
established and strongly promoted which
is currently not the case
and i really want to zone in now on
obesity which you mentioned
it is of course a major risk factor for
becoming seriously ill from covet 19.
why is that exactly
so obesity is the main risk factor for
the development of several comorbidities
so
that predisposed for a severe course of
a covet-19 infection
that includes especially hypertension
type 2 diabetes mellitus and
cardiovascular diseases which are all
known to be responsible
that people get seriously ill but also
in the absence of these comorbidities
obese people are at a higher risk for a
severe covered knighting course
as most obese persons are in a state of
a pre-diabetes
that also increase the risk of infection
now there's also been some focus on the
role that vitamin d
could play in helping to protect against
the virus
what can you tell me about that
so for a well-functioning immune system
vitamin d is
of course essential besides other
vitamins and minerals
and therefore in adequate supply with
vitamin d is also essential to
protect us against invading pathogens
and also the
um against infections like with saskoff
too
there are currently some discussions
about daily supplementation with vitamin
d to support our immune system in the
fight against covid19
however if we look into the currently
available studies there's no evidence
provided that a high-dose vitamin d
supplementation
prevents from a saskov2 infection or
would help to
a better recovery from an infection
indeed what we should definitely avoid
is a state of vitamin d deficiency
in case of an approved vitamin d
deficiency of course vitamin d
should be supplemented and in case
people would like to supplement vitamin
d
although as i mentioned evidence is
currently missing
they should make sure that they not
exceed the recommended daily
upper limit of 4 000 international units
okay and now of course we all have
different dietary needs but what general
advice would you have for
boosting immunity during this time
so that our immune system will work well
well um i recommend to stick to a
plant-based diet containing high amounts
of fresh fruits and vegetables
that provide high amounts of essential
vitamins and
nutrients and i recommend also to
consume whole grain foods when it comes
to
cereals or bread and also include pulses
in the daily diet as they are fiber rich
and i furthermore suggest to stick to
vegetable oils with
high amounts of polyunsaturated fatty
acids
and what we should do is to lower the
consumption of for example sugar
sweetened beverages and sweets
and also we should limit the consumption
of meat
okay and finally this is a question
that's come up a few times
is there any risk of being infected with
the coronavirus
through food
so the data that is currently available
does not show any case where an
infection occur through
contaminated foods however when we
prepare food we should stick to the
hygiene rules
this means of course we should regularly
wash our hands keep our fingers away
from
from the face and also if we prepare
meat we should make sure that it is
heated
through all good tips
professor annika wagner from the
institute of nutritional sciences at the
university of giessen thank you so much
thank you time now to answer one of your
questions about the coronavirus over to
our science correspondent derek williams
what impact is the pandemic having on
the hunger crisis
predictably covet 19 is making it a lot
worse
according to the united nations world
food program
which is the organization that was
awarded this year's nobel peace prize
the number of people worldwide who
suffer from crisis level hunger
could almost double by the end of this
year
it also says that the region hit hardest
so far
is latin america that's followed by
central
and southern africa and and oxfam
estimates that if we don't do more
to limit the social and economic impact
of the virus
up to 12 000 people a day could soon be
dying from the effects
of undernourishment um just to compare
even on the very worst days for
mortality so far
in the pandemic there have never been
more than 10 000 deaths
attributed to the virus in 24 hours
i think that the most vicious aspect of
this crisis is that with the exception
of a few countries food is actually
available
in many of the places that are suffering
most
famine isn't being only driven by a lack
of food
but also by the simple fact that people
no longer have the means to buy it um
the hunger crisis
isn't only expanding rapidly because of
disruptions in supply chains although
that's
certainly contributing to the problem
it's also due to dropping
income among many of the world's most
vulnerable the poor
who simply can't afford to buy food for
themselves
and their families anymore and the
crisis isn't just limited to regions
that faced
problems before the pandemic began covet
19
is now also impacting food security for
people in
middle and high income countries from
from
india to brazil to the us
you